weirdly part of the target you got hocus pocus
too that's for me i got a little mermaid a little
mermaid and then we both have like a pretty
beautiful amount of enchanting yeah yeah
yeah it's good this has been a perfect disney
day for us ladies and gentlemen we have it the
official teaser trailer for the little mermaid i'm
looking forward to it i'm also looking forward to
everyone who wants to you know those people on
the internet saw the thumbnail and i was like
oh yeah i remember hearing stuff about that
thing i remember the conversation surrounding
this movie i'm excited for the comments i'm
gonna judge this trailer solely based off of
you know what the trailer's giving us which i
imagine is reminding me of that great cartoon
that's gonna be better all right
let's check it out leave a like too
holy moly
i want to be where the people are dude
i know it looks like funny neighbor
aquaman
oh dinglehoppers and thingamabobbers
i goosebumps be
part of that world
i love the little mermaid i really do yeah there's
like a certain handful of disney movies that i
really grew up watching a lot and the little
mermaid was for sure one of those films so
for a nostalgia trailer this
worked on me like nobody's business
yeah that magical anticipation i'm like oh my god
they're bringing it to life for real yeah this is
funny scene because you know it's like a lot of
animated you know cgi and stuff going for the
real world effect so to see it sometimes it looks
like finding nemo other times looks like aquaman
that's what the animation blend looks like
there was something just sweeping about it to me
and very moving and touching i honestly found
it just incredibly touching and i know it's
only because i love the little mermaid but maybe
yeah i am maybe i am wondering maybe if i didn't
even really have that fondness for the little
mermaid or hadn't seen it that i might have
still been encapsulated by the the imagery and
and the tone because it doesn't show you a lot
no but i think that's part of the charm of of this
as a teaser is it draws you in and it just shows
you where it just shows you how they're realizing
the sea and especially her little you know chamber
of collections you know it gives you just enough
yeah that you can yeah just sort of feel the aura
and the vibe and you can kind of feel the magic
that she must experience being able to zip in
and out of all these different coves and things
you know it it has a very elemental quality well
that moment in in the movie because that is such
a defining character point for for aria in that
scene so i felt like just even getting a little
bit of of slow moving on her as she's singing
getting a look at her body language her expression
because her voice is fantastic but that sense of
longing and wonder and desire all in her eyes i
was like i'm weirdly getting a lot out of this one
shot and i don't know if it's my nostalgia just
projecting so much onto like hey this looks great
or like because to me it was it was really hitting
and yeah i thought it was beautiful and i i like
uh like i mean the actual co i don't care that
she's black uh like the the actual costume itself
looks a little cosplay to me to be honest well
they gotta make it like a full tube thing cause
they they can't give her the shells they would
never if it makes no sense to me if they're
gonna take them they're gonna take the beer out
of pinocchio they got to take the shells out of
a little mermaid it does look it does look uh to
me that it was that was the one part of it that's
like it looks like a costume yeah it looks like
something you got on the shore on land instead
of something that you made down here however you
know that is like my one little thing that i know
when watching it it's not like
watching like weird cgi you know
like maybe this film will have the official
trailer and then i'll be like a lot of weird
yes we got a little there was a little we
saw flounder from behind but we haven't seen
like actual you know talking flounder
oh i know always by seth rogen that's
not real i think you should go to the surface uh
we have lots to see i know you guys see triton
we got to see ursula and all that and and like
i even like the little mermaid too really yeah
with arielle's daughter wow is it good yeah it is
i'm gonna watch it tonight ursula's sister no good
my daughter my sister my daughter my sister yeah
i mean that's that's i'm a big little mermaid i
didn't know this about you people probably
wouldn't expect that from me it's weird but that
is my jam i thought i loved the little mermaid
i thought that was a great film that's probably
the girl like that's one of the disney movies
growing up that i saw the most as well and
that i always had on and yeah this did give me
like i really liked how this teaser and again
i feel like the official trailer is going to be
a different experience and i'm open to that but
i just love the mood and the aura because this
definitely brings you back to the original but
it has this like sense of space where i was
like i could almost watch a movie where her
heel is just on her own you know hopefully
i mean hopefully one day we get that john
um yes guillermo del toro's little mermaid well
you know i think the thing is and graham there's
a very specific sequence they're they're honing
in on is that a big part of uh in the sea it's
like it's got to feel very vibrant and colorful
and i don't know what they're going to be going
for with the animals it looks like they're going
for that like lion king photo realistic [__]
and i feel like you gotta but it's like you
can't go to pinocchio where it's like it's just
like so animated yeah you know you gotta find the
right there's gotta be some middle ground jungle
book uh there's gotta be like some kind of middle
ground you gotta find there or else it can look a
little strange yeah so i i think there's a lot of
vfx work that has to be done and it's disney so
you know they're gonna let them take their time uh
this is a theatrical are we yeah oh yeah they're
but they will whip crack those animators
way more than they did on pinocchio make
that fish look real that's not photo real do it
again sebastian doesn't look like a real crab
there's too much facial movement this does not
look like an anthropomorphic octopus woman take
it back so yeah i think it looks great um i do
too what time period is it in when she becomes
a real girl with legs and stuff yeah black girl
is it gonna be step into a very racist world
yes yes and then what's the prince's name
prince philip or whatever he's gonna eric
is this one that's right they all got white dude
names but prince eric the best one of them all
i know i just remember his dashing looks but yeah
he'll have to you know start a whole civil rights
movement and that'll take over the movie and then
uh you know then he'll be forced to go live in
the sea i love this trailer i'm really looking
forward to it it looks beautiful i think so too
i am the target market for this and there's
probably like little girls and like the girls
who grew up on this oh no i'm the great weirdly
part of the target you got hocus pocus too that's
for me i got a little mermaid little mermaid
and then we both have like a pretty beautiful
amount of enchanted yeah yeah yeah so it's good
this has been a perfect disney day for us yeah
all right guys thank you for being here
this looks great i'll talk to you soon